schönen guten tag wir sind live mit zdf
heute live schön dass ihr dabei seid
zweiter tag des g 7 gipfels im
bayerischen schloss elmau am vormittag
haben die staats und regierungschefs mit
dem ukrainischen präsidenten selensky
gesprochen er war per video zugeschaltet
vielleicht können wir die bilder dazu
auch gerade einspielen genau da sehen
wir ihnen und die staats und
regierungschefs wie gesagt präsident
selensky war per video zugeschaltet und
die staats und regierungschefs der g 7
haben im weitere hilfen versprochen
humanitär finanziell und auch
militärisch und zwar so lange wie nötig
heute nachmittag sind dann fünf
gastländer dazugekommen indien
argentinien indonesien senegal und
südafrika mit den schwellenländern aus
dem süden wollen die g7 vor allem über
klimaschutz und die aktuelle
lebensmittelkrise sprechen
jetzt gleich in wenigen minuten soll
kanzler scholz vor die presse treten und
wird über die ergebnisse dieser
gespräche berichten und vorher wollen
wir mit dem leiter des zdf
hauptstadtstudios in berlin sprechen mit
theo koll der jetzt gerade den gipfel
für uns verfolgt von garmisch
partenkirchen aus hallo
hallo
schön dass sie bei uns sind am gestern
wasser so dass es erst mal das große
hallo und das get together und das
familienfoto gab heute ging es nun
wirklich an die großen wichtigen themen
und dabei herrscht der krieg in der
ukraine die agenda wie nehmen sie die
atmosphäre vor ort war
interessanterweise entspannt
offensichtlich trägt auch der ort der
viel kritisiert wurde dass es hier ein
ganzes tal gesperrt wurde und dass die
kosten dramatisch sind mit fast 170
millionen wurde es beziffert aber das
scheint sich zu lohnen also ich höre von
teilnehmern aus dem inneren dass die
atmosphäre sehr entspannt sein
miteinander und insgesamt also gestern
abend ist emanuel makro mit seiner frau
bridget spazieren gegangen
er hatte damit dem handy geleuchtet boys
jones ist heute morgen baden gegangen im
wahren wortsinn also das miteinander ist
offensichtlich auch hilfreich bei den
gesprächen und das ist ja ein teil
dieses wertes den diese g7-treffen
ausmachen dass man sehr offen in
entspannter atmosphäre miteinander die
großen fragen diskutieren kann dieser
gipfel sie beschreiben ist ja da hat man
den eindruck der ist ja auch vor allem
einer der bilder die in die welt
rausgehen sollen wie sie gerade
beschrieben haben die spazieren gehen
das spazierengehen ehepaar makro der
kanzler mit dem us-präsidenten der
kanzler mit frankreichs präsident max
rudow mit japans präsident und boris
johnson im arm dahinter steckt doch eine
sehr klare botschaft oder
absolut also das ist ja heute im grunde
ein teil von politik also visuelle
politik ist reale politik das signal ist
ganz klar in die welt und natürlich vor
allem an putin wir stehen zusammen deine
hoffnung dass der westen sich spaltet
über diesen krieg und über die folgen
die folgekosten sind ja dramatisch und
damit auch unglaubliche belastung in den
einzelnen gesellschaften also das signal
das von hier aus gehen soll ist ganz
eindeutig wir stehen zusammen und wir
stehen auch langfristig zusammen das ist
auch ein teil der themen heute gewesen
wir hatten ja
die schaltung sie haben sie eben erwähnt
schon von präsident selensky aus der
ukraine
und da ging es natürlich erwartbar um
waffen es ging um munition das hat er
ganz klar gemacht dass er die dringend
braucht aber es ging natürlich auch um
den blick nach vorn also
was bedeutet dieser kriegsverlauf wie
lange wird der westen zu der ukraine
stehen auch unter den dramatischen
belastungen die wir alle sehen also wir
erleben beim gaspreis in deutschland
alle anderen nationen ja auch weil die
energiepreise steigen die inflation ist
dramatisch hoch gestellt also das sind
stressfaktoren in den
gesellschaften die wiederum die ukraine
unterstützen und da war es ganz wichtig
der ukraine zu sagen wir werden
langfristig zu euch stehen langfristig
heißt während des kriegs das heißt aber
auch danach es wurde also auch heute
darüber gesprochen was heißt das für den
wiederaufbau da weiß man natürlich noch
nicht genau wie dramatisch wird die
ukraine zerstört sein wie groß sind die
folgekosten aber auch da hat der westen
gesagt wir werden beim wiederaufbau
präsent sein wir werden helfen und es
geht um die zeit danach denn man muss ja
im grunde wie auch immer der krieg
ausgeht für die ukraine wenn es die
ukraine weiter gibt und davon geht der
westen hier aus dann muss man ja
irgendeine form von sicherheits
arrangement finden ein security dream
and und das war auch heute eines der
themen das man da gewährleisten will und
der ukraine signalisiert hat wir werden
dann für euch da sein wir warten hier
gemeinsam auf die pressekonferenz von
kanzler scholz und sie begleiten uns
dann und werther weise theo daniel
thompson hat den tag bisher für uns
zusammengefasst schauen wir uns kurz an
es ist der gipfel marathon gipfel
marathon ein bilaterales treffen folgt
aufs nächste auf den indischen premier
folgt der argentinische präsident
gespräche mit den gastländern darunter
auch indien indonesien und senegal
stehen heute nachmittag im mittelpunkt
die g7 wollen die verbindungen zu diesen
großen schwellenländern stärken
wirtschaftlich im kampf gegen
klimawandel und krankheiten aber auch
mit blick auf den krieg unter druck
setzen lassen würde man sich aber nicht
machte vorab im gespräch mit dem zdf die
aussenministerin südafrikas deutlich die
themen die zum krieg zwischen der
ukraine und russland geführt haben sind
gegenstand der globalen debatte seit
mehr als zehn jahren und afrika wurde
nie eingeladen um mit am tisch zu sein
dies zu diskutieren da kann man nicht
jetzt sagen entscheidet euch für diese
richtung oder die andere
am vormittag war der ukrainische
präsident zugeschaltet laut
teilnehmerkreisen forderte er massive
hilfe für ein kriegsende noch in diesem
jahr von den g 7 die veröffentlichten im
anschluss eine erklärung mit
symbolträchtiger formulierung man werde
die ukraine kontinuierlich finanzielle
humanitär militärisch und diplomatisch
unterstützen und zwar so lange wie nötig
as long as
ebenso werde man gegen die hungerkrise
zusätzliches geld zur verfügung stellen
so kanzler scholz am morgen und
gleichzeitig bemühen wir uns zusammen
mit dem generalsekretär der vereinten
nationen mit dem wir heute auch sprechen
werden darum dass es gelingt zum
beispiel aus der ukraine getreide zu
exportieren da sind jetzt gegenwärtig
tag und nacht die verhandlungen im gange
auch heute gab es erneut zahlreiche
proteste meist eskortiert von der
polizei betreut ist demonstrieren
zwangsläufig 50 menschen durften
zumindest in sichtweite des schlosses
ihre kritik äußern
sie haben über jagd nur eine politik
gemacht die nicht mensch und natur des
internets es sind viele
herausforderungen viele und vor allem
vielschichtige krisen die die
sogenannten schlossherrn die g7 staats
und regierungschefs auch über diesen
gipfel hinaus fordern werden
und wir warten darauf dass kanzler
scholz sein statement abgibt zum g 7
gipfel zum zweiten tag an diesem montag
ich möchte die gelegenheit nutzen um
euch zu sagen dass ihr viele
gelegenheiten haben werdet fragen zu
stellen oder kommentare loszuwerden die
postet ihr am besten die chats oder ihr
schickt uns eine mail theo koll ist bei
uns leiter des zdf hauptstadtstudios in
berlin und
beantwortet einige dieser fragen ich
fange mal an warum schreibt eine frage
ist es denkbar indien zu sanktionen zur
beteiligung an den bestehenden
sanktionen gegen rosten russland zu
bewegen
es ist denkbar aber es ist
unwahrscheinlich bis ausgeschlossen ich
würde mich für letzteres entscheiden ich
halte es für ausgeschlossen die position
von indien ist ja
hochkompliziert auf der einen seite
braucht indien die usa vor allem in der
auseinandersetzung zum nachbarn china da
gibt es ja immer wieder auch grants
reibereien und die beiden riesen im
grunde in asien sind
konfliktträchtig und da braucht indien
und sucht indien die unterstützung der
usa aber auf der anderen seite darf man
nicht vergessen dass indien ein lange
gutes verhältnis hat zu russland indien
hat drei viertel seiner waffen aus
russland bezogen oder auch aus alten
sowjetischen beständen das verhältnis
zwischen mode und putin soll exzellent
sein also auch das persönliche
verhältnis und
indien profitiert natürlich auch jetzt
die sanktionen bei der energie bei kohle
und öl die verkauft putin jetzt zum teil
mit rabatt an indien also indien soll so
heißt es bei der kohle einen
30-prozentigen rabatt von russland
bekommen haben und da ist natürlich
vielen nationen das berühmte hemd näher
als
die jacke oder der rock also ich gehe
davon aus dass indien diese sanktionen
nicht unterstützen wird ähnlich ist es
übrigens bei ländern wie senegal das ja
auch hier eingeladen war der
bundeskanzler war im senegal und hat
dort vom staatspräsidenten dann gehört
ja aber das sind doch eure westlichen
sanktionen die dafür sorgen dass wir
eine ernährungskrise haben dass der
weizen nicht rauskommt also da war
offensichtlich die russische erzählung
im senegal die glaubwürdigere des
derwesten sagt ja aber die häfen der
ukraine sind von den russischen
militärkräften gesperrt worden und der
weizen liegt in der ukraine und kommt
nicht raus millionen tonnen das wurde da
nicht als die version angenommen die im
grunde die wahrheit ist also insofern
ich glaube man muss realistisch sein und
darf da keinen neuen illusion erliegen
wie leicht
seitenwechsel sein würde bei diesen
ländern daher auch in dem beitrag von
daniel pontzen die südafrikanische
außenministerin gehört die ja im prinzip
gesagt hat naja also früher habt ja auch
nicht mit uns geredet
so salopp gesagt warum kommt ihr jetzt
ist das auch so ein bisschen die haltung
jetzt brauchte er uns und jetzt redet
ihr mit unserem früh ab dass nicht mal
absolut der westen in an friedrich wenn
man das so nennen darf kommt da einfach
sehr spät und kommt belastet in diese
gespräche und in diese neue weltordnung
man darf nicht vergessen viele der
länder haben eine koloniale geschichte
hinter sich und haben keine guten
erfahrungen mit dem alten westen der ja
auch in den g7 vertreten ist also die
ganz großen kolonialmächte frankreich
und england großbritannien sind da
vertreten aber auch die usa hat ja eine
eine lange geschichte von sehr
schwierigen
konflikten die sie auch in die welt
getragen und dort ausgetragen haben und
das hat dazu beigetragen dass in vielen
ländern der westen belastet ist wir
sagen natürlich immer es bahnt sich ein
konflikt an zwischen demokratischen
staaten und autokratischen staaten aber
das sind jetzt auch demokratische länder
die eingeladen sind und die trotzdem
diesen alten westen sehr kritisch sehen
lassen sie uns noch einmal auf diese
gastländer eingehen die
eingeladen waren also es sind indien
indonesien südafrika senegal und
argentinien hier kommt noch mal die
frage auf warum das ausgerechnet diese
fünf länder wagen
weil man gesagt hat wer repräsentiert
den globalen süden auf vernünftige weise
indien einfach durch seine schiere größe
mit über einer milliarde menschen sehen
egal vertritt im moment die afrikanische
union also ist dort im vorsitz südafrika
auch ein großes ein großes land der
großer player argentinien vertritt im
moment den zusammenschluss in
südamerika also man hat versucht
demokratische vertreter zu finden die
aber eine große region hier mit an den
tisch bringen
und vielleicht gehen wir noch mal kurz
auf das gespräch mit dem ukrainischen
präsidenten selensky ein er hat mehr
unterstützung gefordert und die g7
staaten haben ihm das im prinzip
zugesagt so lange wie er das braucht
ging es auch ein bisschen konkreter in
der einzelheiten oder war das nur so ein
allgemeines versprechen
also das ist ja noch kein ist ja noch
kein communiqué darüber bekannt geworden
was ich gehört habe geht es ja auch
indirekte unterstützung indem man
weitere sanktionen gegen russland
beschlossen hat also man hat
jedenfalls einige der staaten haben den
gold export von russland mit sanktionen
überzogen oder werden ist russland ist
ja ein wichtiger und großer gold
exporteur da geht es auch um viele
milliarden und auch den verdacht dass
oligarchen den mittels gold die
sanktionen umgehen dann hat man gesagt
man wird weiter technologie exporte
sanktionieren das sind also technologie
nach russland geht die möglicherweise
für die rüstungsindustrie dort
eingesetzt werden könnte und man will
solle die man auf russische exporte
erhebt dann gleich an die ukraine
überweisen um der ukraine zu helfen also
das sind eine eine reihe von sanktionen
die man jetzt noch weiter einbringt die
natürlich dann indirekt auch der ukraine
helfen ich habe aus den gesprächen
gehört dass selen ski offensichtlich die
große sorge hat dass russland das putin
nicht damit zufrieden sein könnte den
osten der ukraine zur u bahn sondern er
sieht offensichtlich das risiko dass es
einen neuen versuch geben könnte die
gesamte ukraine einzunehmen
ich schaue noch mal in den chat welche
fragen es da noch gibt
egon gold möchte wissen kann damit
gerechnet werden als antwort auf die
verlegungen russischer atom fähiger
rakete nach belarus das abwehrraketen
ebenfalls verlegt oder aufgestockt
werden
da bin ich überfragt um ehrlich zu sein
ich bin kein militärexperte und müsste
die frage auch noch mal recherchieren
kann ich kann ich nicht so beantworten
tut mir leid das ist überhaupt kein
problem vielleicht können wir das in der
redaktion klären und vielleicht noch
nachreichen denn adhoc können wir sie
auch nicht verantworten
eine weitere frage von bern ist eine
weitere unterstützung der ukraine durch
schwere waffen konkret zu erwarten oder
nur ein vages versprechen
ich würde jetzt mal davon ausgehen dass
wenn die deutsche unterstützung meint
also es scheint in die richtung zu gehen
dass wir immer mehr liefern bisher war
ja die klare maßgabe dass man versucht
die ukrainischen truppen mit alten
sowjetischen beständen auszurüsten aber
weil die hand abwehren und sehr schnell
lieferbar ist also über diese ringtausch
jetzt zeigt sich aber immer stärker dass
es kaum noch munition gibt also es gibt
noch munition in brasilien brasilien ist
aber einer jener staaten also der brics
dieses zusammenschlusses in dem unter
anderem russland ist die sich weigern
diese alte sowjetische munition an die
ukraine zu liefern also es wird
zunehmend schwierig keine modernen
westlichen waffen zu liefern da gibt es
eine reihe von bedenken offensichtlich
so höre ich jedenfalls dass man sorge
hat dass die nicht richtig bedient
werden können dass es viele
waffensysteme moderne waffensysteme eine
erhebliche logistik erfordern also dass
im grunde vorne eine hightech waffe
fährt und dahinter ein großer logistik
zug der gebraucht wird um die waffe in
stand zu halten und so weiter und so
fort und die sorge das ist vielleicht
auch den russen dann in die hände fällt
also dennoch in der mange lung von mehr
beständen alten sowjetischen russischen
waffen würde ich erwarten dass der
westen mehr und mehr liefert und an
dieser stelle wollen wir noch mal in die
ukraine schauen glück war port hat dazu
führt sein gemacht
heftige angriffe russischer truppen
erschüttern weiter die stadt ließ
chelsea im osten des landes aus der luft
und vom boden werde die stadt mit feuer
überzogen so der gouverneur die lage sei
sehr schwierig zivilisten sollten die
100.000 einwohner stadt sofort verlassen
weiter westlich bringt der zivilschutz
bereits bürger vor den vorrückenden
russischen angreifern in sicherheit
ich fahre zur oma weit weg von hier
es gibt kein gas kein wasser kein strom
drei stockwerke des hauses sind
weggebombt
am nachmittag wurde ein einkaufszentrum
mitten in krementschouk 300 kilometer
südöstlich von kiew bombardiert 1000
besucher seien im gebäude gewesen sagt
präsident selensky es werden zahlreiche
opfer vermutet im russischen fernsehen
bestätigte die armeeführung
raketenangriffe auf viele orte in der
ukraine
betont wurde man nehme nur militärische
infrastruktur ins visier getroffen
werden aber stattdessen immer wieder
wohnhäuser wie gestern in kiew ein toter
sechs verletzte darunter ein kind trotz
der bedrohung nahmen die menschen in der
hauptstadt heute ihre arbeit wieder auf
an das g7-treffen in deutschland knüpfen
sie vorsichtiger hoffen
ich hoffe dass sie uns helfen werden es
wäre jedenfalls ein wichtiger schritt
für unsere große zukunft
präsident selensky hat die hoffnung
geäußert dass der krieg bis zum einbruch
des winters beendet werden könnte
und während wir eben mit theo koll dem
leiter des zdf hauptstadtstudios in
berlin gesprochen haben in garmisch
partenkirchen begrüßen wir jetzt sarah
packung sie ist russland expertin bei
der deutschen gesellschaft für
auswärtige politik hallo frau tagung
frau packung wir haben gerade erfahren
bei diesem g7 gipfel geht es sehr darum
geschlossenheit zu zeigen welchen
eindruck dürfte das auf dem russischen
präsidenten putin machen
also hoffentlich natürlich aus
westlicher sicht einen großen vor allen
dingen durch die fotos auch durch die
symbolischen bilder die gezeigt werden
nichtsdestotrotz kommt man in moskau
natürlich ganz genau darauf was wird
dann konkret beschlossen und da sehen
wir eben dass auch hinsichtlich der
sanktionen beispielsweise ist eben nicht
dazu kommt dass wir möglicherweise
wirklich große fortschritte hier auf dem
g7-gipfel sehen sondern das dann auch
abgewartet werden muss was die eu sagt
und wie die verhandlungen dann
weiterlaufen
die g 7 haben neue sanktionen
beschlossen die ziele neben vor allem
zum beispiel auch auf die
rüstungsindustrie wie empfindlich würde
sowas russland treffen
also das sind natürlich erstmal
sanktionen die usa beschlossen hat das
trifft den russischen rüstungssektor
schon ganz einfach weil die
us-sanktionen eben auch einen so
genannten extra territorialen effekt
entfalten das heißt er sprüht oder er
geht auch auf andere staaten über damit
kann man sicherlich langfristig die
rüstungsproduktion behindern wir müssen
uns allerdings vergegenwärtigen dass
sanktionen eben nicht eine große
sanktionen beinhalten die dann der große
wurf ist sondern dass es eher darum geht
ein möglichst dichtes netz an wirklich
enges netz zu konstruieren um mögliche
schlupflöcher zu verhindern und eben die
russische wirtschaft die russische
rüstungsindustrie wirklich in der breite
zu schwächen wie steht es denn aktuell
überhaupt um die zahlungsfähigkeit von
russland die usa sagen ja die stehen
kurz vorm zahlungsausfall und der kamera
sagte stimmt überhaupt nicht
also die situation die wir haben das
wirklich eine ganz besondere weil der
zahlungsausfall den wir jetzt hier
kürzlich gesehen haben von russischer
seite nicht dadurch bedingt dass
russland kein geld hand sondern dadurch
dass dieses geld durch vor allem die
us-sanktionen eben nicht an die
gläubiger an die gläubigerin kommen das
heißt eben nicht dass im russischen
staat aus geld ausgibt sondern dass das
bedienen von krediten von anleihen für
den russischen staat insbesondere
westlichen ausland immer schwerer wird
das hat kurzfristig erstmal noch gar
nicht so die großen auswirkungen es geht
aber sicherlich langfristig um die
kreditwürdigkeit und auch um die zinsen
die russland für stars sondern für
kredite zahlen wird jetzt wird ja noch
dieser preis deckel für russisches öl
diskutiert was würde der bringen und ist
das überhaupt realistisch dass die
starken damit
also das problem was wir bis jetzt sehen
bei den sanktionen und öl und gassektor
ist ganz einfach dass durch die
steigenden preise
das was der russische staat mit öl und
vor allem auch gas verdient eigentlich
sogar über dem liegt was wir im letzten
jahr gesehen haben sprich die sanktion
anfallen hier im nicht hinfällt die man
sich von westlicher seite gewünscht hat
die idee eines preis deckels soll eben
genau das verhindern das problem ist
dass die g7 alleine hier zwar ein effekt
erzielen können aber vor allen dingen
einen begrenzen und das heißt sie muss
hier wirklich nach partner nach
partnerin ausschau halten die bei diesem
preis beckel mitmachen würden sei es auf
angebotsseite oder auf nachfrageseite
und das ist die crux und ob das gelingen
wird am ende das werden wir sehen ich
bin ehrlich gesagt auch etwas skeptisch
vielleicht noch eine frage dazu von
adrian jones der fragt wie ist denn
aktuell die lage in russland die
installationen sind ja doch schon eine
ganze weile in kraft wie es die
wirtschaft was haben wir jetzt soweit
beantwortet aber er fragt wie steht denn
das volk zugute
[Applaus]
also der blick in russland zeigt einzig
eine nach wie vor relativ breite
unterstützung für den russischen krieg
um der ukraine das ist natürlich mit
einiger vorsicht zu sagen da
beispielsweise umfragen in autoritären
system immer sehr mit vorsicht zu
genießen sind man unterliegt natürlich
dann bei den umfragen zwängen ja sagen
die menschen wirklich die wahrheit offen
sprechen sie wenn wir uns aber im umfang
anschauen beispielsweise für die
unterstützung putins dann ist leicht
gestiegen also wir können eben nicht
davon ausgehen dass das was wir bis
jetzt sehen die steigende inflation auch
die wirtschaftskrise die in russland
ausgelöst wird wirklich dazu beiträgt
dass die russen hier die unterstützung
versagen sondern eigentlich eher das
gegenteil ist dieser klassische the flag
effekt die eigentlich dazu führt dass
die leute eher noch dichter an den start
herangeschafft werden
vielen dank frau tagung für den moment
und wir würden jetzt mal hochschalten zu
schloss elmau zu alissa jung unserer
reporterin hallo alissa du hast uns
hallo ich und ich stehe hier direkt vor
schloss elmau ich gehe mal ein paar
schritte weiter nach vorne dann sieht
man das schloss auch in seiner ganzen
pracht und ihr könnt es sehen wir warten
hier sehr viele journalistinnen und
journalisten auf das presse statement
von olaf scholz sehr ist aber noch nicht
da ist scheint sich noch ein bisschen zu
ziehen und zwar weil hier in diesem
gebäude mit den fahnen vorne dran wir
können auch gleich noch ein bisschen
mehr hingehen dieses gebäude scheint
noch nicht frei zu sein und dort soll
das segment stattfinden und so lange das
gebäude nicht frei ist beginnt das
statement auch nicht das ist der grund
warum sich das ganze hier noch verzögert
absolutes feier eigentlich für 17 uhr
angesetzt jetzt ist es mittlerweile halb
sechs für warten seit einer halben
stunde und vielleicht kannst du mal was
zu diesen ganzen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sagen denn
hochzukommen zu diesem schloss elmau ist
für für dich und deine kolleginnen und
kollegen auch gar nicht so einfach
genau du sagst es wir sind auch erst
ganz knapp vor 17 uhr hier angekommen
genau aus dem grund wegen der hohen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen
die straße war lange gesperrt ist sind
eigentlich nur rund 20 minuten die man
bräuchte mit dem auto von garmisch
partenkirchen wo wir stationiert sind
bisher hoch zum schloss elmau wäre also
eigentlich gar keine lange strecke jetzt
hat es für uns rund anderthalb stunden
gedauert denn die straßen sind gesperrt
voller polizei es gab ja hier heute eine
kleine demonstration 50 menschen waren
nur zugelassen die durften also hier in
hör- und sichtweite einmalig vor dem
schloss demonstrieren das hat dann auch
nochmal zu noch mehr kontrollen noch
mehr polizei noch mehr sperrungen
geführt also auch wir haben eben in
einem reisebus gesessen sind ein
polizeiauto von polizeiauto vorbei
gefahren und haben also sehr sehr lange
gebraucht zwischendrin auch immer wieder
gestanden und jetzt hat man sich vor
allem auch ich weiß nicht ob man das so
gut sehen kann bei euch brennt da
hintergrund ein bisschen weg wir haben
natürlich auch sorge dass jetzt hier
noch dazu schlechtes wetter dazu kommt
denn ich sehe hier hinter mir also
ringsherum auch in den bergen hängen da
hinten dunkle gewitterwolken bei euch
das bisschen heller aus als bei mir und
wenn es dann auch noch regnet dann wird
das hier bestimmt auch nicht alles
schneller vorwärts gehen auf den straßen
aber es ist einfach so ja tatsächlich
hohe hohe sicherheitsvorkehrungen rund
18.000 einsatzkräfte die unterwegs sind
und das führt dazu dass das einfach sehr
sehr lange dauert bis man hier von a
nach b kommt das ist eine
hochsicherheitszone
der wald durch den wir gefahren sind
schon seit tagen wochen eingezäunt und
das ist wirklich man kann sich das kaum
vorstellen wie hier wirklich eine
hochsicherheitszone um dieses schloss
dieses idyllische schloss elmau
errichtet wurde und während wir auf die
pressekonferenz des kanzlers warten
vielleicht noch ein wort dazu dass diese
hohen sicherheitsvorkehrungen die ja
schon auf zum teil seit wochen getroffen
wurden auch eine große belastung für die
bürgerinnen und bürger in der region
sind
das ist richtig ich habe gestern mit
mehreren menschen aus garmisch
partenkirchen gesprochen das ist ja der
ort unweit von hier wo auch sehr hohe
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sind und da sind
also sehr viele menschen da von
betroffen beispielsweise wurde das
eisstadion der stadt man ist hier sehr
groß im eissport wurde schon im februar
gesperrt dort ist nämlich jetzt die
polizeizentrale und das bedeutet
natürlich für den sport für den eissport
einen totalausfall denn bis august soll
diese sperrung auch noch bleiben
beziehungsweise diese umnutzung des
gebäudes in eine polizeizentrale und
dann habe ich mit dem inhaber des
lokalen eissports geschäfts gesprochen
und er hat gesagt die situation für ihn
gerade ist noch schlimmer als zu corona
zeiten also enorme umsatzeinbußen
aber auch restaurants leiden darunter
natürlich denn der normale
urlaubsreise verkehr wie er jetzt um
diese schöne sommer jahreszeit natürlich
herrschen würde der findet jetzt gerade
in diesem maße ja auch nicht statt das
ist wie ich ja schon angesprochen habe
einfach wirklich eine
hochsicherheitszone und dann vielleicht
auch nicht in diesen tagen der ideale
ort zum urlaub machen und das ist für
die menschen vor ort natürlich schon
auch eine enorme einschränkung sie haben
auch schon seit mehreren tagen wochen
mit diesen straßensperrungen zu kämpfen
kinder können an drei tagen nicht in die
schule gehen da findet distanz
unterricht statt also ihr merkt es gibt
wirklich sehr sehr viele auswirkungen
wegen dieses sehr kurzen gipfels dann
doch für all jene menschen hier in der
region gibt es denn für die menschen
dort irgendeine form von finanzieller
kompensationen wenn ihr zu größere
ausfälle haben
das habe ich jetzt von denen mit denen
ich gesprochen habe in dieser form nicht
gehört es gibt aber das muss man
natürlich auch dazu sagen auch einige
die daran verdienen können die hoteliers
im ferienwohnungen die sind ja trotzdem
gebucht denn ich hab's angesprochen für
die restaurants ist es problematischer
als für die hotels und ferienwohnungen
wo zb wir journalisten auch
untergebracht sind wo auch die polizei
untergebracht ist es gibt einige
restaurants die als catering für
beispielsweise die polizei auch arbeiten
dürfen aber es sind eben nicht alle
restaurants eingebunden und die haben
dann natürlich einbußen von finanziellen
entschädigungen habe ich von den
betroffenen und der 21 ganz unterbrechen
denn wir sehen jetzt dass die
pressekonferenz von olaf scholz es geht
wir geben das großbild drauf danke dem
okay wir haben gerade erfahren dass das
noch nicht das richtige bild ist oder
toll sitzt gerade noch mit dem
argentinischen präsidenten zusammen und
deshalb gehen wir noch mal kurz zusammen
der russland expertin von der deutschen
gesellschaft für auswärtige politik und
machen mit ein paar fragen an sie weiter
schön dass sie weiter weil und sind
oliver trakt auf facebook gibt es denn
überhaupt irgendwelche nennenswerten
erfolge die durch die waffenlieferungen
aus dem westen erfolg sind im osten der
ukraine hat die ukraine die kontrolle an
der front mittlerweile verloren
also ich würde sagen sogar sehr große
erfolge alleine der militärische erfolg
der ukraine die einnahme bemühungen der
russischen streitkräfte von kiew zurück
zu halten da wirklich auch zurück zu
werfen ist doch wirklich ein sehr
beachtlicher ein sehr großer erfolg mit
dem ja vorher einzel auch kaum jemand
gerechnet hat die probleme in dem am
donnerstag bei der verteidigung würde
ich eher darauf beziehen das ist zum
einen sich die russische kriegsstrategie
geändert hat man geht jetzt sehr
konzentriert mit sehr viel liebe
artillerie-beschuss auf einzelne punkte
vor und man muss natürlich auch sagen
dass der westen gerade auch deutschlands
insbesondere mit den waffenlieferungen
liegt dafür für diese verteidigen
notwendig dann doch relativ lange
gewartet hat
hat der westen denn mit den sanktionen
die dann jetzt heute kommen sollen oder
in den nächsten wochen einen
entscheidenden hebel oder kann müssen
das kompensieren mit hilfe anderer
partner
russland ist natürlich in der lage ein
teil der sanktion nicht nur der jetzt
beschlossenen auch der vorherigen zu
kompensieren wir sehen beispielsweise
das muss man verstehen nach indien
exportiert nichtsdestotrotz sehen wir
vor allen dingen anhand der russischen
wirtschaftsdaten doch einen erheblichen
effekt dass es wird einen wirtschafts
stumpfen im zweistelligen bereich für
2022 erwartet und das sind eben
erhebliche effekte die inflation steigt
deutlich zum ende des jahres auch wieder
am anstieg der arbeitslosigkeit und
russland vor allen dingen in den eher
abgelegenen ländlichen gebieten zu
rechnen und von daher müssen wir eben
oder können nur ganz klar sagen dass die
sanktionen an erheblichen effekt haben
dass sie kurzfristig dazu führen dass
russland seine meinung zur version ende
hat wieder getroffen abzieht das war
ohnehin nicht zu erwarten
es geht eher darum wirklich die
ressourcen für diese kriegsführung auf
russischer seite deutlich zu beschränken
und während wir auf die pressekonferenz
vor
falls baten die ihr eigentlich gegen 17
uhr beginnen sollte unsere reporterinnen
alice der junge hat uns gerade erzählt
dass das gebäude noch nicht frei ist und
das ist der grund warum sich das ganze
etwas verzögert sprechen wir mit sarah
packung einer russland expertin von der
deutschen gesellschaft für auswärtige
politik lassen sie uns über den aspekt
hunger noch mal sprechen der ja eben
auch auf dem g7-gipfel ein großes thema
ist heute kam die meldung dass der
weizenpreis auf den tiefsten stand seit
beginn des ukraine krieges gefallen sei
und dass die weltweite getreideernte
laut vereinten nationen bunten
wesentlich geringer ausfallen wird als
2021 was was sind das für zeichnung
bedeutet dass entwarnung dass die
situation am ende vielleicht doch gar
nicht so dramatisch ist
nein also entwarnung würde ich hier in
jedem fall nicht gehen weil die
grundlegenden faktoren die zu dieser
nahrungsmittelkrise ja ausgelöst ist ja
stark steigende preise geführt haben
weiter bestehen das ist eben zum einen
die blockade ukrainische exporte durch
durch russland dabei euch durch das
verminte schwarze meer der erschwerte
zugang zu russischen weizenexporte
aufgrund der sanktionen vor allen dingen
aber auch die steigenden kosten die
produktion von düngemitteln
beispielsweise wird eben durch die
gestiegenen energiepreise deutlich
verteuert und das hat natürlich letzten
endes auch auswirkungen auf die
nahrungsmittelpreise von daraus müssen
wir damit rechnen dass es nur einem jahr
ein kurzfristiges aufatmen ist mittel-
und langfristig müssen wir eben weiter
mit sehr stark gestiegenen preisen
rechnen neben vereinen für die ärmeren
länder ein noch viel größeres problem
sind als für die reichen staaten der g 7
liebe frau tagung vielen dank für den
moment wir sprechen später nochmal
weiter und gehen nochmal hoch zum
schloss elmau zu unserer reporterin
alissa jung
alisa das war eben ein kleiner fehlalarm
das war noch gar nicht dass presse
statement von olaf scholz auf das wir
warten hast du mittlerweile was gehört
wenn es losgeht
ich hatte mich auch schon gewundert weil
dann hätten wir das alle hier gar nicht
mitbekommen nein wir warten hier immer
noch es ist tatsächlich so ich würde
euch mal mitnehmen zu dem gebäude um das
es geht um das investieren möchten
eigentlich also laufe hier gerade mal
durch all die von uns die hier warten
und hier hinter mir in diesem gebäude
soll also gleich das statement von olaf
scholz stattfinden es ist aber noch
nicht frei wir sehen hier zugezogene
vorhänge also warten wir hier alle und
hoffen dass es nicht regnet aber stand
jetzt wer hat hier keiner von uns an
informationen wie schnell oder langsam
das noch dauern könnte leider nicht
lasst uns mal über das programm auf
diesen g7 gipfel sprechen die staats und
regierungschefs haben sieben große
sitzungen in drei tagen auf dem programm
stehen plus eben diese ganzen
bilateralen gespräche untereinander
unter vier augen
diese zeit hat man den eindruck wird
intensiv genutzt wie konkret sollen die
ergebnisse dieses gipfels werden
das ist die entscheidende frage das ist
auch die frage die alle menschen die ich
in den letzten zwei tagen getroffen habe
die gegen den gipfel auf die straße
gehen und die also heftig kritik äußern
die frage die sich stellen und vor allem
das was sie sich wünschen konkrete
ergebnisse und wirklich etwas konkretes
was da zu papier gebracht werden soll im
gegensatz dazu steht natürlich das auch
immer wieder betont wird dass das und
dass der g 7 gipfel ein treffen ist vor
allem auch ein treffen zwischen eben
diesen sieben demokratischen nächten um
sich auszutauschen um in ruhe sprechen
zu können ein format was es also so in
dieser form sonst nicht gibt und
deswegen ist die große frage wie konkret
das am ende wird ich glaube das lässt
sich jetzt zu diesem zeitpunkt eben nur
sagen und da braucht es dann also morgen
natürlich noch die abschluss stellt man
es um zu sehen was da wirklich dann am
ende passiert ist und worauf man sich
einigen konnte denn es gibt ja auch noch
immer einige punkte die noch offen sind
und vor allem es ist ja auch noch heute
abend der abend ein weiteres abendessen
was eben für genau diese lockeren
informellen gespräche genutzt werden
soll und um sich auszutauschen und es
ist ja wirklich also jetzt noch heute
der ganze abend morgen der morgen noch
zeit um da noch etwas zurück konkreter
zu werden als wir das bislang gehört
haben und
an du bist ja oben vor schloss elmau und
ganz viele kolleginnen und kollegen sind
unten in garmisch partenkirchen und von
denen bekommen wir gerade die
information dass wegen des wetters du
hast es ja eben schon angesprochen das
wetter so ein bisschen unbeständig keine
flüge hochgehen zu schloss elmau de
gehen ja die ganze zeit die
helikopterflüge hoch und runter und
deshalb würde sich die pk eben auch
verzögern weil journalist innen nicht
dort hoch kommen kannst du das
bestätigen krieg so was der um mit
also nach uns sollte noch ein weiterer
bus fahren ich hatte es ja eben schon
berichtet dass wir also selbst ja auch
über anderthalb stunden gebraucht haben
ob dieser bus jetzt auch fest steckt in
einer der kontrollen oder sperren das
kann sehr gut sein ich habe jetzt auch
die nämlich nicht weitere menschen noch
ankommen sehen und die sache mit den
helikoptern das stimmt auch bei
schlechtem wetter können die natürlich
nicht fliegen und das ist jetzt
tatsächlich für den nachmittag abend
auch regen gemeldet das scheint sich
hier in den bergen aber auch nicht ganz
anti minute zu halten denn der regen war
eigentlich auch schon vor etwas ja
früherer zeit gemeldet wenn ich mich so
umschaue hier hinter uns ist es auf
jeden fall recht wolkig aber ich habe
noch keinen tropfen abbekommen aber das
kann natürlich auch noch ein grund sein
dass wir hier warten müssen weil es
einfach so lange dauert hier auf dieses
schloss zu kommen dann alles ringsherum
ist gesperrt und dann ist das natürlich
auch einer der gründe warum sich hier
sowieso immer alles sehr lange zieht und
verzögern das ist richtig und da wir so
gar keine information und kein hinweis
haben wann es denn jetzt losgehen würde
sagen mir die kollegen gerade dass wir
an dieser stelle stopp machen sollen und
den stream beenden sollen die walliser
vielen dank du wirst uns weiter auf dem
laufenden halten und natürlich sehen wir
die pressekonferenz dann auf den online
seiten von ctr freute oder eben
natürlich auch in den vielen vielen
nachrichten sendungen die wir haben
alles
okay da war sie schon weg ich darf mich
für eure aufmerksamkeit bedanken und
sage danke an dieser stelle es war ein
bisschen
unverrichteter dinge machen wir jetzt
schluss aber ich glaube wir haben
trotzdem am vieles uns erklären und
einschätzen lassen danke an dieser
stelle bis bald
[Musik]